Welcome back everyone let's put a smile on
that face this is going to be my joker 2 video
that's right dc is making a joker sequel to
joaquin phoenix's joker movie i'll explain where
it would fit in the timeline overall continuity
because we do have multiple batman movies coming
out this year between the batman movie with
robert pattinson in the flash movie with both
michael keaton's batman and ben affleck's batman
if you're new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos between all this new joker
and all the batman movie sequels and spin-offs
that matt reeves has planned right now it is a
really good time to be a batman fan in some of
the dialogue from the first joker movie seems
so much more apropo now is it just me or is the
world getting crazier out there given what's
happened the last couple of years in the real
world but the big news you've probably seen in
all your timelines today is that warner brothers
has set a tentative start date for production on
joker 2 with todd phillips and joaquin phoenix
next year in 2023 which does line up with
what todd phillips and joaquin phoenix said
a couple years ago after the first joker
movie came out they both went back and
forth over whether or not they'd ever actually
do a sequel but eventually todd phillips said
that it would be a good long while in joaquin
phoenix said he would totally come back as long
as the story was right the team was right and
it sounds like they worked all those things out
i can't stop thinking about it i talked to tom
a lot about what else we might be able to do
in general just working together but also
specifically is there something else with joker
that that might be interesting you know i think me
todd would still be shooting now if we could right
because it seemed endless um the the possibilities
of where we could go with the character
and if they didn't start filming till 2023 that
means a 2024 release date which would be a good
long while between movies it's still going
to be rated r is still going to be part of
dc's black label which is what they're using for
their darker more hardcore films especially ones
that are set in alternate universes that aren't
necessarily connected to all the big dc eu stuff
most of the plot details are being kept in
an underground bunker as you would expect
but based on what both phillips and phoenix had
said previously the movie isn't going to have
like a massive time jump the original movie took
place during 1981 joaquin phoenix is in his 50s
in present day and real world but he was playing
a 30 40 something joker in many of the different
canonical origin stories for the joker there are
at least three of them that are considered canon
including the most well-known version
of his origin the red hood version
joker is much older than bruce wayne was when he
became joker most versions of joker are meant to
be between 10 and 15 years older than batman
minimum the version of bruce wayne that we
met in the first joker movie in the universe
where this takes place gets his crime alley
origin story at the end of the movie when this
universe's version of joe chill follows thomas
and martha wayne with bruce as they leave the
movie theater having just watched zorro the
gay blade the reason why todd phillips used that
zoro movie is because that movie came out in the
real world in 1981 the year that this is supposed
to be happening in the world of the joker movie
in different batman movies you see them use
different films for his origin story or in the
case of christopher nolan's dark knight trilogy
they were watching the opera mephistopheles
and that's officially the closest you'll ever
get to a mephisto easter egg in the dc movies
in the way they intercut all the different ending
scenes for all the characters in the film bruce
wayne's parents are being killed at the same time
joker's being hoisted up by the crowd painting
the smile on his face with his own blood and it's
meant to be a parallel for bruce wayne getting his
iconic origin story moment in joker's officially
becoming joker from the comics but the way they
intercut the scene of him at arkham asylum right
after that in the way they play with perspective
music the bloody steps you're meant to question
whether or not everything that happens during this
ending during all these ending scenes were just in
his head like did he just fantasize about all this
probably assumed when we all first saw it in the
theater the simplest answer is usually the most
correct with scenes like this all the scenes of
him being hoisted by the crowd and painting the
smile on his face actually happened bruce wayne's
parents were really killed by this version of joe
chill just like in the comics and then a little
while after the events of this scene more law
enforcement and riot gear are brought in to shut
the crowd down they arrest joker again haul him
into arkham asylum and then over a short period
evaluate him with psychiatrist as we see happening
in this scene here in the way that all of batman's
biggest villains get studied and picked over by
scientists and mental health professionals when
they get thrown in arkham asylum what's so funny
and i do think that he actually did kill this
woman the psychiatrist but when you see him
walking down the hallway leaving the trail
of bloody footprints and the music swells up
that part is all happening in his head like he's
in the process of escaping from arkham asylum
but the way the prison break plays
out in this scene it's meant to be his
fantasy version of things if we were to
see what's actually happening here in
reality you'd see him running down the hallway
covered in blood crashing through random people
orderlies looking for the exit stabbing people
left and right it would be way more quick and
dirty like some of the other killings that
he did during the film the movie does this
a couple times where it shifts between his
perspective and reality like his fantasy
and what's actually happening like all the earlier
scenes with zazi beats where he imagines them
beginning this relationship having all
these dates together but then you find
out that none of that actually happened the
way that he imagined it was all on his head
the whole payoff in her apartment was meant
to teach you how to interpret the ending
prepare you for the ending like yes a version of
these things are happening but not in the exact
way that they're depicting it on screen because
at this point it's become his fantasy version so
now that we're getting a sequel i know you're all
asking about a version of batman appearing like
what's the continuity will the sequel connect with
any of the other versions of batman that we know
because there are a lot of versions of batman that
we're going to be seeing in the next year too just
based on what todd phillips has said in the past
based on the current timeline of the 1980s when
this is all taking place the sequel will probably
not connect with any of the upcoming batman movies
mostly for practical reasons it's not meant to
connect to the batman movie with robert pattinson
because one the timeline wouldn't even make sense
his movie set around the late 2010s like very
close to our real world present day this lincoln
navigator is recent model so walking phoenix's
joker would be in his early 70s during the events
of the batman movie just wouldn't make sense in
michael keaton's batman who's the closest
to joaquin phoenix's joker in terms of how
the ages line up already had a version of joker
in his universe played by jack nicholson with a
wildly different origin story so joaquin phoenix
is not meant to be the tim burton version of joker
willie get a load of me todd phillips talked
a lot about this when the first movie came out
he said his whole deal was that he just wanted
to do his own thing in his own little pocket
universe without having to connect to any of the
other pre-existing movies matt reeves actually
just said the exact same thing about the robert
pattinson batman movie you may have seen people
talking about this in your timeline recently matt
reeves talking about the ben affleck version of
the batman movie when they first brought him in
to work on the batman movie they actually asked
him to direct the ben affleck version of the
batman movie matt reeves said that he read that
script and said that i don't want to have to deal
with all this pre-existing baggage and all these
connections he just wanted to do his own thing
his own very self-contained batman movie in todd
phillips's joker movie is also meant to have that
same kind of energy like very self-contained very
much its own thing so any references to batman or
any of the other pre-existing dc characters in the
joker sequel is just meant to be a coincidence
or in the case of this version of batman just a
totally new different version of batman you don't
have any dream uh to be in a scene with batman
no i haven't had that i haven't had that dream
that dream we'll see it could be coming because
the batman is coming so who knows and instead
of jumping forward 15 to 16 years to show little
bruce wayne here as an adult wearing the cape
and cow the joker sequel is mostly just meant
to move forward a little in the timeline to the
next logical event in gotham and some of you may
have seen that really cool willem dafoe interview
where he talks about playing a version of joker
fantasizing about being in the joaquin phoenix
joker movies his idea for how that would play out
sounds legit it actually makes sense but willem
dafoe said that he actually wanted to play a joker
imposter in the joaquin phoenix joker sequel it
would be the true joker joaquin phoenix's version
versus imposter jokers who rose up inspired by
what he did during the events of the first movie
like you have to imagine willem dafoe playing
a character watching the broadcast of murray
franklin's tv show live when joker killed
him gave his speech to the camera and gets
inspired by that in a really twisted way
there was even a really good fan made edit
of him as joker you may have seen recently as my
father used to say son your teeth are air cooled
so the idea would be the joker goes to arkham
asylum then a copycat or multiple copycat jokers
start to appear and the movie is more about
playing that out so bruce wayne would still
be a child living with alfred he'd be
a little bit older but still be a child
and there wouldn't be a bunch of batman stuff
happening yet and if you are a big willem dafoe
fan it does sound like sony wants him to come
back for more spider-man movies and spin off sony
movies in the future like the venom the morbius
movies they're doing a lot of different spin-off
films with spider-man characters as they're also
planning on bringing back toby maguire spider-man
and andrew garfield spider-man in future movies
but if you have any other questions about what's
going on with the joker movies the sequels
just write them in the comments below and
i'll add them to my future videos everyone click
here for my brand new marvel secret invasion
first look breakdown and easter eggs and click
here for my brand new batman trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!